[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il doit aller au bouillon divisé doigt
les eau douce et ne termine
on utilise qui va battre le record du
monde du 50 km marche
vivez maintenant dont le dernier virage
didn't ou qui donnent tout incroyable
défendre
cette foule comme c'est parti
en cinq minutes et 25 secondes me suis
dit pourquoi pas essayer de battre la
tentative de record du monde tient et
tout un sur piste à reims puis offrir ça
à la ville mes proches à tous les gens
qui me soutiennent leur offrir une vraie
course une course de niveau avec un vrai
chrono j'ai fait trois heures 35 27
donc elle record du monde sur piste
qu'elle deuxième chrono de tous les
temps
sur sur la distance pistes et routes et
pense que c'est la course la plus
aboutie sur le 50km quoi le plus
maîtrisé quoi à 186 jours de son épreuve
olympique
yohann diniz entame une longue marche
qui le mènera à londres c'est un
événement majeur pour ce grand champion
qui a pour unique objectif d'obtenir une
médaille sur 50 km marche
c'est dans ce contexte que nous le
suivons dans les coulisses de sa
préparation avec près de 6000 kilomètres
parcourus par an diniz répète
inlassablement ses gammes cette
obstination a fait de lui un géant de la
route
son palmarès parle pour lui à 28 ans en
2006 il devient le premier français à
devenir champion d'europe à göteborg
il confirme l'année suivante en étant
vice champion du monde à osaka après
avoir abandonné aux jeux olympiques de
pékin
amoindri par une mononucléose il est
attendu de pied ferme pour les
championnats d'europe à barcelone en
[Musique]
au 5e km j'avais 50 secondes avance et
moi en fait après j'ai joué avec ce
petit matelas
durant toute la course pour usé
mentalement mes adversaires notamment il
y avait cardia pied
qui était champion du monde en titre il
avait gagné en 2009 à 10h dacoury enfin
il y avait que des gros clients et j'ai
je vois en fait avec leur mental c'était
un bon bon bon jeu de poker
alors
j'aime de la musique ça dérange pas
[Musique]
pour 50 aux harmonies sont toutes les
épreuves pour un moment muller qui
s'installe et ben tu dénature un peu ton
geste et tout ça quoi et donc il faut
être costaud pour pouvoir compenser par
sa musculature d'efforts qui va prendre
le dessus sur la fatigue quoi quand on
travaille sur des sites comme ça en gros
deux entre trois et quatre semaines
maximum août à bloc et a pas un jour de
repos tu fais ça s'appelle voir les
nouveautés de l'année c'est de
travailler justement cet aspect un peu
technique au niveau du bassin vous pour
essayer de marcher plutôt en ligne un
peu comme les russes quoi marcher sur
une île comme cela parce que moi j'ai
plus tendance à marcher un peu comme ça
mais ce que ben tu vois ils ont une
technique très particulière où il s'est
mis une quoi et ils sont ils marchent
tous pareils quoi donc moi je suis un
peu atypique par rapport aux eaux
photo primée ce matin tu refais une
heure et demie ça te fait déjà trois
heures après tu veux refaire une petite
heure tu es pratiquement 1 4 heures dans
la journée quoi
[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer céline
ma femme qu'est venu en fait inscrire
reprendre l'athlétisme
fin 2002 à l'euphrate m'a fait prendre
conscience de me dire écoute si tu as
envie de persévérer dans ce sport donne
toi les moyens et moi je serai lot
passeront plus derrière toi je suis
derrière toi
et là je dis à céline à partir de la
semaine prochaine
je me mets vraiment quoi le geste
auguste du marcheur yohann les
découverts enfants à epernay en voyant
passer les forçats du paris-colmar
marché sans courir nécessite de poser le
ballon à terre la jambe tendue l'autre
pied reste en contact avec le sol
cette posture obligatoire nécessite la
présence de nombreux juges chargés de
contrôler la régularité de la lure
malgré ce dispositif
le jugement reste très subjectif car non
perceptible à l'oeil humain
et les sanctions sont impitoyables au
bout de trois cartons rouges pour marché
incorrect les athlètes sont disqualifiés
immédiatement par les juges
je m'en vais en afrique du sud mercredi
tout tombe un peu en même temps parce
que forcément les gens ils savent que là
j'étais sur place donc ils sont un peu
calé leurs choses en même temps donc là
tu rentres à peine de l'entraînement
tu auras en chaîne
pour aller faire une sollicitation
médiatique
et puis après tu rentres chez toi tu
essaies tu te reposer un peu et puis
thoretton à l'entraînement parce que moi
là en plus c'est pour la bonne cause que
c'est pour l'association
je soutiens
donc c'est pour un peu faire parler
d'eux du clip qu'on va tourner et demain
soir
olivier coyette voilà et d'en changer
d'ère aujourd'hui je vous l'annoncé je
reçois donc yohann diniz yohann diniz
double champion d'europe sur 50 km
marche bonjour alors vous êtes sur ce
plateau du 13 heures avec vous pour nous
parler aujourd'hui d'un clip que vous
allez tourner demain à rance pour une
bonne cause une maladie peu connue
ça se traduit par un trouble
neurologique caractérisée par à part un
besoin irrépressible de de bouger en eau
qu'avec de sérieuses répercussions sur
le sommeil alors pourquoi ce soutien
vous avez accepté tout de suite c'était
lui les jambes c'est important c'est les
gens me sens évidemment on la marche et
ça ça collait tout de suite à mon image
donc il n'y a pas eu
j'ai tout de suite accepté il ya aussi
jean jacques goldman qui tient un milieu
aussi modeste on va dire quand j'étais
plutôt jeune
donc je partais pas tout le temps en
vacances et ensuite après j'étais
animateurs moniteurs en colonie
une sur des choses on a beaucoup
travaillé justement avec des gamins du
secours populaire la croix-rouge ainsi
de suite des gamins qui est pas trop
d'argent et ouais enfin moi c'est tout
le temps toute façon c'est une cause là
on va dire
les causes sociales c'est quand même
quelque chose pour lesquelles je réponds
souvent
oui diniz n'a pas toujours marché droit
son adolescence et tumultueuse il se
perd dans le milieu de la nuit puis fait
d'autres rencontres et s'engage dans le
militantisme à la lcr
objecteur de conscience il fait son
service civil puis obtient un emploi
jeune dans un club d'athlétisme à reims
et par curiosité il s'essaye à la marche
ils en maîtrisent le geste presque
instinctivement
devenu sportif de haut niveau il garde
ses valeurs et n'hésite pas à s'engager
politiquement toujours le coeur à gauche
citoyen engagé passionné d'oenologie de
cuisine de musique et de littérature
diniz est multiple
l'ofs
alors vous marcher avec nous
sortie
c'est à une heure et demie de
johannesbourg que yoann et son team
décide de poser leurs valises en plein
été austral
le bénéfice est attendu car situé en
altitude à 15 cents mètres et sans
décalage horaire potchefstroom doit
conclure en beauté son cycle d'endurance
hivernale
alors on va faire un peu de renforcement
musculaire à nouveau 40 500 euros son
positionnement de simba le bricoleur
cette année on a plutôt choisi dans la
première partie de faire un peu de 20
kilomètres donc pour redorer un peu le
secteur vitesse de marcheurs on a décidé
de faire du 20 km en début de saison
et puis la deuxième partie de la saison
a consacré surtout à la préparation
spécifique du 50 km donc une préparation
axée beaucoup moins sur la qualité c'est
à dire des séances courtes avec de
l'intensité mais beaucoup plus sur le
développement de l'endurance qui reste
le coeur de l'épreuve du 50 km puisque
lui c'est vraiment dans la durée qui le
qu'il excelle la séance a démarré la
pluie s'arrête donc ça c'est bien vrai
ap 10
le lève le pied
[Applaudissements]
attention promettre pour camper dans la
forêt
4,15 impeccable
les français patrimoniaux maria la cvs
concombre 16 mois il était bien la fin
de la baule et me casse les pattes un
sas et des exercices qui sont vraiment
pas facile à l'entraînement parce que
l'un ni la motivation de la compétition
et a plutôt le stress doit d'avoir mal
d'en chier de voir est employé mais ça
va cintra qui va lui servir pour lugano
quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour même temps
[Musique]
à l'égout
donc là on a fait deux minutes douche on
a préparé longtemps maintenant l'ol est
à 34 degrés maintenant on veut faire
[Musique]
français
inutile
allez watts
je te dis rien
encore 5 à 0
taha
à
[Musique]
si sur les hauts plateaux du transvaal
johan parcours entre 160 et 190 km par
semaine c'est pour remettre la machine
en route
après six mois sans compétitions et un
échec cinglant lors des derniers
championnats du monde à daegu en corée
du sud
favori il avait été contraint de
s'arrêter au bout de 17 km me suis
retrouvé seul
tout de suite les russes ils ont pas ou
lui envoyer donc après je me suis dit
bon bah les cocos moi je veux pas me
retenir la course commence
et puis voilà au bout de trois
kilomètres j'ai déjà un rouge ou 9e j'ai
un deuxième rouge et au 15e kilomètre un
troisième round
chaque course chaque jour est différent
et c'est un jugement humain donc tu peux
pas tu plais pas tout le temps à
toulouse
yoann a tiré les leçons de daegu échange
donc son approche des grandes
compétitions
il ira chercher la confrontation à
l'international avant les jeux et
surtout il montrera son style et son
déhanché au juge afin qu'ils s'habituent
à sa démarche atypique
[Musique]
partout
moi
[Musique]
cette ville
[Rires]
c'est un homme courageux
j'ai caressé n'y est pas
[Musique]
à
52 6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baudis
[Musique]
deux caps
voit le procès ce qui permet d'être bon
cette pensée que tu vas peut-être pas
arrivé à faire les choses et le procès
ce qui limite les moyens c'est penser
que tu vas aller faire les choses
aujourd'hui tu fais une belle séance le
but suprême ça se fait que tu arrives à
faire ce truc là en compétition c'est à
dire que tu n'es pas besoin de le faire
à l'entraînement pour aller à la
compétition il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
ne soit pas capable de le faire même si
c'est plus compliqué de le faire en
compétition mais ça c'est un truc je
veux que tu comprennes c'est capital en
vue des jeux
salut à demain amusez-vous à demain
louise de midi pyrénées
par contre on a fait avec cet hiver
c'est à dire les compétitions de
déplacés
ça commence aujourd'hui
en a pour à peu près 26 mois de
compétition pas été lâché un peu dans la
fosse et c'est bien d'avoir tes proches
autour de toi pour la première
compétition d'année puisqu'il ya tout le
temps d'une certaine appréhension
le début de saison quoi
[Musique]
le jour d'une bonne tête mais c'est pas
vraiment un bon mais parce que tu as la
petite vie au ventre l'appréhension
l'adrénaline surtout quand c'est la
première compétition de l'année
tu sais pas trop quoi voilà il y aura
pas d'enseignements à tirer à 100% après
cette course parce que c'est la première
c'est la première
car
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en suisse 10 nice concours pour un 20 km
il retrouve de sérieux concurrents comme
le champion olympique du 50 km à pékin
en 2008
l'italien alex schwazer ou encore le
prometteur boîte et malté barondeau pour
chasser les doutes nés de son échec
mondial yoann mais les gaz et suit le
rythme effréné de ses adversaires les
allures sont vertigineuses et choix de
serre après avoir disparu des tablettes
pendant trois longues années montrent
qu'il sera bien à londres pour défendre
son titre allez à youtube la gagne
sur les bases depuis 17 45 niveau
mondial bic niveau mondial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des ronds galway nos bons côtés
somme record une 17 40e
record battu d une quinze record de
france et surtout c'est des meilleures
paires mondiales tout en danse et si
peur moi je suis toujours en vie si tu
restes parce que tu deviens stalric là
on se met derrière puisqu'il va ça y est
je trouve un lien qu'il avançait ben je
doute qu'un petit peu mais bon ils
savent qu'ils gagnent ouais je lui offre
la victoire
je lui dis je lui dis je t'emmerde
évasif je t'amène à la victoire donc ce
n'est pas faire ça comme le dit pascal
mais c'est mon côté encore généreux mais
sera moins généreux en jeu j'espère que
le classement il versera aux jo sixième
meilleure performance mondiale de tous
les temps sur 20 km le chrono de yoann
est d'autant plus important que
l'italien schwazer sera contrôlé positif
à l epo
quatre mois plus tard
alors à quoi ressemble accord qui vient
de faire un vin board regarder en face
de toi la tête pour regarder s'il ya des
tensions spécifiques
t'as fait quoi tu as fait de deux jours
cousin sélections qui tire la twa jeu je
m'attendais à te voir beaucoup plus
raide que ça après après un premier
vingt bornes attend à la haye a une
particularité sur la marche c'est c'est
cette fameuse démarche au niveau du
bassin c c'est par définition c'est pas
physiologique donc il faut être
il faut être vraiment apte à faire
d'énormes compensations parce que tu
sois sens si on marche vite abandonné
obligés de courir donc pour parcourir
d'objets de déporter le bassin au dessus
de la tête du fémur par contre ça mérite
d'avoir un bassin qui est toujours
parfaitement équilibré le moindre
déséquilibre c'est soit une pubalgie
soit une sciatique soit soit des
tendinites à répétition donc là il faut
vraiment on est obligé d'accélérer mans
énormément sur le préventif alors trente
secondes encore relâche bientôt la
cuisse
c'est mon cul une petite tape sur le cul
et c'est fini
[Rires]
après sa perf de lugano yoann trop
fatigué abandonnera une semaine plus
tard au meeting de dudince en slovaquie
la phase de repos programmée en bretagne
arrive donc au bon moment il est
accompagné de cédric houssaye équipier
en club et en équipe de france et ce par
une partenaire sur de nombreux stages
ça va la température donc ça c'est un
mélange d'algues laminaire et de fucus
pour un effet drainant et aussi pour la
décontraction musculaire et articulaire
ça va comme ça tu peur à terre
l'intérêt c'est que tu peux pas garder
la forme de mars à août
donc forcément d'autres ont la casc
c'est à dire nous sont la casse ou sont
des entretiens quoi
mais c'est difficile à part resté
disponible on va dire frais et dispos à
quoi surtout les chevaux tout au long
l'année
ceux qui sont en forme en bas de mars tu
la trouveras jamais au mois d'août
j'ai tous une petite douleur
intercostale
[Musique]
lors du stage de carnac et yoann ressent
des douleurs de plus en plus vive dans
le dos ces douleurs persistantes
le poste à faire une scintigraphie
osseuse afin de se rassurer donc on a
des selles elle est bien là a priori
elle aurait
deux semaines comme le geste de la
marche on va chercher avec son bras loin
derrière loin derrière comme d'un
mouvement brac est comme ça donc on va
chercher loin derrière et forcément la
cei tient sa et tire je tire sur l'os et
puis ça me fait super mal quoi passer
une fracture de fatigue alors c'est
parce que c'est lié à l'effort quoi
c'est l'effort la répétition du geste
qui a fait que l'os et casser quoi aix
les bains stade chant forestiers sous le
terrain d'entraînement de christophe
lemaitre yohann diniz doit se rendre à
l'évidence impossible de marcher avec
une côte fracturée diniz enfourche donc
son vélo à nouveau le seul sport qui lui
est permis avec la natation un coup
d'arrêt simplement provisoire il y a
quelques jours diniz a recommencé la
marche avec londres en ligne de mire
à cause de sa blessure diniz n'a pas pu
se rendre en russie pour une épreuve de
coupe du monde dans le temple de la
marche à saransk totalement remis il
dispute ses onzièmes championnats de
france avec comme objectif une victoire
et un septième titre d'affilée depuis
son record de france sur 20km à lugano
diniz reste aux yeux du public
une sérieuse chance de médaille aux jeux
olympiques et sa popularité ne fléchit
pas tous les athlètes étant présents
lors de ces championnats
la fédération a organisé dans un gymnase
annexes la remise des lots aux
olympiques
bonjour messieurs dames ça vient
bienvenue dans l'antre sur place ça sera
mieux qu'à pékin j'espère mazel tov ça
c'est pour le podium
le garde
observant que vous n'êtes pas bloqué
c'est sûr ça fait très beau chercher lui
même semblait d'ailleurs t'as intérêt à
chercher cette médaille d'or d'appel
c'est vous s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
messieurs les marcheurs s'il vous plaît
thomas shannon ouais merci quinio
lardini ce qu'une fille dans la rue vous
êtes situe alors que vous étiez cité
s'il vous plaît
voyons
il va partir comme un voleur façon dont
je vais faire un petit délinquant ou de
paraître
[Musique]
mon fils peut il et nous pendant ce mois
ci campion aux terrils et merci au qatar
les championnats de france sont l'ultime
étape avant le stage en altitude
programmé à font romeu l'effort d'un 50
km et en plus violent qu'un marathon les
organisateurs ont préféré préserver les
marcheurs avant les jo sans rival
capable de le pousser dans ses
retranchements dinis fait le boulot
son emprise sur la discipline est
criante et la course est une simple
formalité pour lui
c'est aux avant postes il remporte le
titre en 39 minutes et 46 secondes à
plus de 15 km heure de moyenne
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
ah ouais
je suis franchement chat je disais au
mac do you do hd ce qui est pour nous
plus important c'était mon ter pourront
ne avec la certitude qu'on n'avait pas
de 70 régler avant de rentrer vraiment
une vie du sujet merci
[Musique]
on me dépêche parce que j'ai un contrôle
antidopage ouais t'as et rendent bien
bon courage
d'autre part l'occasion voix à font
romeu
mais bien avec les boules quand même je
te dirai quand est ce que je suis sur un
cycle de repos comme ça on en fera une
après midi
pour yoann l'échéance olympique se
rapproche à grands pas en se rendant
dans les pyrénées orientales
il rentre dans la dernière phase de
préparation de son année olympique
au menu bouffer du bitume encore et
encore
à raison de 25 à 40 km par jour sans
compter les séances de stretching et de
musculation la 8 semaines c'est la
première fois que je vais faire aussi
donc ça c'est une bio c'est une manière
de se protéger on a ses habitudes
on sait comment fonctionne on sait
comment mon corps réagit par rapport à
l'altitude
je ne me loin de toute l'agitation
médiatique qui va bientôt arriver à
partir de début juillet un seul écart
est prévue à ce programme
pas question pour lui de rater le
traditionnel meeting international de
reims champagne-ardenne organisé par son
club de toujours
c'est bon on préfère elle est belle bon
j'espère que le soleil sera de nouveau
présent demain c'est parce qu'ils disent
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour ça va
[Musique]
sinon sur la course tu
mais changer compagnie way pour la gagne
c'est l'étude livre pas trop tôt pour et
puis quand tu va accélérer sa va
s'accrocher à toi donc tu prévois un
mois de galas chatroulette
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas du genre en marche sur
l'analyse mais autrement
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
encore un dernier effort
elle était l'équivalent la réserve une
il est redescendu les pollens et la
réforme salariale
celle là complètement
ouais ouais
cooper
[Applaudissements]
entheca l'e book for envoyée
c'est vraiment totalement engagée dans
six incidents
il remporte dans thierry campion et paul
avait d'abord ce site
ça va
[Musique]
merci m
sa remontée à font romeu si les pollens
sont tombés si jamais ça va pas parce
qu'on l'a on a eu tous formés par la
situation et on ira sur le mexique
entraînement complet non grasse battre
le touquettois convoqué
[Musique]
je partais à font romeu lundi enfin le
dimanche soir je suis partie de dimanche
soir en avion
dès que je suis arrivé là bas je ça
n'allait pas trop des symptômes qui
revenait quoi
minet qui commença à se reboucher mal
aux oreilles des étourdissements des
vertiges
pascal le mercredi midi m'appelle ils
n'y vont ils rentrer jeudi matin après
l'entraînement toujours pas cette année
le pollen la pollinisation est intervenu
super tard moi je suis super sensible à
ça
puis de plus en plus donc il faut
composer des fois avec avec des éléments
et
extérieur
[Musique]
vermelles
et puis là vraiment la gelée des très
très belle séance quoi là il n'y a pas
de soucis quoi je vous prêt à faire mal
aux rita les eaux russes comme moi il
faut que j'arrive à être performant le
jour des jeux les déboires à pékin j'ai
pas envie j'en chat ça fait quatre ans
qu'on parle de pékin à chaque coup
combes retard donc maintenant c'est
londres et voilà j'ai envie de repartir
de l'ombre avec du positif
alors que les gens ont commencé à
londres cédant le pas de calais que
yoann termine sa préparation il y reste
deux semaines avec dans les premiers
jours la présence et de soutien de sa
petite famille
le touquet a été choisi comme base
terminal diniz préfère peaufiner la
tactique avec son coach plutôt que de
végéter une dizaine de jours au village
olympique les jeux ils les regardera
mais de loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces quatre partis ont la mèche où il
n'est pas très bien il était bien là les
peuples puissent qualifient leurs
congénères non non non
troisième le mes études à mal couru
pasquale battu par spearman mais la
patrouille bon donc ce matin on fait 10
d'échauffement ans qu'il en soit 5000 e
donc tonnes de riz et toi tu peux
intervenir si tu le veux deux fois sur
500 m l'idée c'est toujours essayé de
perturber l'adversaire soit
effectivement en répondant immédiatement
tu y mets le doute soit en laissant soit
3,4 m c'est à dire qu'il est attaqué
sauf qu'on prend 3,4 m et toi taxer la
progressivement et que tu restes à 3,4 m
toualy décès il a d'abord une jouissance
qui salit les mains
et puis après il immédiatement un doute
[Musique]
la rue saint-jean et douilles
c'est très peu au chocolat et
mignardises là il fait un ut la maison
voilà tu m'en diras les nouvelles par
étapes
ça c'est du salon passif à celle
affichée
je vais peut-être lâché t des trucs aux
écarts la lingette ce sujet mais le
système est un homme sage si je fais
on parle de lessive et pour les on fait
quoi maintenant
l'ebita de l'épilation je la fais pas
encore comme toi tu m'as m
il ne reste plus que trois jours à yoann
à attendre son épreuve
quand il prend connaissance des détails
de la disqualification du champion
olympique en titre
alex flatteur l'italien de 27 ans qui a
été contrôlé positif à l epo explique
également que son entourage ne
connaissez rien ces pratiques tu es la
maison et tu attends que ta fiancée
parts à l'entraînement pour renfermer
dans la salle de bain et de faire les
piqûres de p o j'ai tout fait seul car
je ne voulais pas causer d'ennuis à qui
que ce soit depuis 2010 je n'avais plus
de bonnes sensations et dans la
perspective des jo je n'étais plus
lucide je me suis mis la pression tout
seul je voulais revenir encore plus fort
il était champion olympique bien quoi et
après ne jamais rien tu vois 2009 ont
merdé sortie de nîmes elles disent merde
2011 bat là là tu vois c'était tu vois
il est mentalement il était
dévorée par ce à quoi parle de 50 bornes
j'ai testé du code juillet je n'ai rien
fait de mal
bonne chance alors pour samedi à roanne
a battu son bar
j'étais d'hier sur la rai culture envers
les j'étais à 120 on prend le meilleur
la séance j'ai eu l'impression de
c'était vraiment pour conclure sur ce
que tu pose comme question j si ça
marche à ces vitesses là t'as rien à
faire quoi t'as pas juste attendre que
ça se passe confie dessus puis après ben
quand lui prendra ce sera pareil plus
vite et là normalement il n'y a pas cent
cinquante mille personnes
mais wayne avoir la conscience qui se
tenir très longtemps ce mur les mecs ils
vont payer cher de leur peau pour mourir
parce que les jeux que tout le monde
veuille bélaye quoi je te disais il ya
trois médailles mais tu en as 9 ou 10
qui doivent penser être pouvoir être au
top
m
bon ça y est l'été dans la dernière
ligne droite donc
ça monte progressivement quoi
l'important c'est pas de faire péter la
soupe abl
une semaine avant la course quoi la
pression sur la laisse s diffuse
lentement tranquillement et puis
arrivées concentrer le jour de sa course
bas
mais l'individu va passer au 32e km en
deux heures 25 17
quel sera son temps final 2 heures 25 10
10 dont 2 heures 25 si c'est bon signe
dans ma mois il a même pas de tente 3h48
ouais pourquoi 148 monsieur vous avez
perdu c'était 3h47 julian voilà et ses
vaches et aux nombres la classe et le
parc olympique en construction
[Musique]
c'est
s3 deuxième étage est là qu'on fait
d'auto au placebo joli travail c'est
bien
mais là
là
[Musique]
depuis 2006 c'est lui le meilleur c'est
lui le meilleur depuis 2006
malheureusement bon il ya eu des élus
des petites choses bon
il ya eu pékin et berlin et daegu mais
quand il est bien dans sa tête quand ils
pensent vraiment qu'à sa course et qu'il
est il est vraiment
bien bien dans les dents les consignes
ben il va au bout quoi il va au bout et
il est meilleur que tout le monde
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est parti on va aller se
positionner le seul à faire du bruit
allez go go go go you
[Musique]
[Rires]
ban
non non non c'est en 49 minutes allaient
aux
tac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
mais moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que j'ai vu les russes prendre la
tête c'était plutôt bon signe quoi ça
voulait dire que ça allait être une
course tactique par le haut que je veux
dire toute cette partie sur des rythmes
les faits remonteraient à fermer tout de
suite avoir quand même un gros écrémage
quoi celle à qui ma baguette magique ne
propose pas de trois heures plus tard
c'est bien
genève au quarantième bougie russe qui
reste là et puis j'ai tout de suite vu
que ça pleuvaient les cartons je voyais
des juges qui regardaient dans le groupe
de tête et puis hop c'était le carton ça
passait pas devant moi c'était derrière
c'était à lui de vent sur le côté mais
jamais moi donc si je suis reste
concentré mobiliser je fais pas le con
aujourd'hui ma marshall et
réglementaires
l'italie dépend peut-être est-il un
vêtement il accomplit l'habitat bull
allait me produis la table je passe un
peu de vent mais pour contrer bon et
coco je suis pas crever s'il faut
marcher en cas de bain il n'y a pas de
soucis moi je montre jusqu'aux telle à
quoi il a été présent deviendra je
rentre vivant
moi je sens cardiaque n'est pas au mieux
et bakouline il fait des signes ouais on
y va excellent moi je prends la tête je
suis à côté d'une division on y va tous
les douches d'eau non mais j'y vais pas
je me sens super bien on va arriver au
35e j'ai envie d'y aller j'ai des super
bonnes sensations et puis
je passe devant et là pascal après qui
me redit
bio pas maintenant c'est pas la trouille
allait enfin
tranquille reste derrière puis d'après
pomme
thaçi noac'h attaque dans la ligne
droite devant pascal bats après demi
tour il attaque puis la jv pas parce que
juste avant je dois pas y aller je pense
que c'est là que la course qu'elle s'est
joué que moi parce que j'y suis pas allé
enfin je suis pas allé avec le chinois
parce qu'il n'y avait rien à faire un
effort violent quand même bon et puis
après ça comment ça allait moins bien
parce que je prends un coup de chaud
joie pascale qui donne des conseils et
je le regarde tu vois je le regarde
alors que d'habitude je regarde pas tu
vois je reste concentré je reste la tête
droite et là j'ai besoin de chercher son
regard tu vois pour me rassurer tu vois
pas ce que je ne suis pas très bien
puisque retrouver un peu pro les
barrières je ne peux tu as eu lieu le
pied derrière trucs à la con quoi ça me
fait mal tu cogites u10 bon allez je
vais repartir je m'arrête pour marc rozé
parce que j'ai mal pour reprendre pour
reprendre mes esprits
ainsi de suite bon et puis la presse il
finit quoi c'est fini après je m'arrête
encore comme on l'a dit après je
m'arrête encore deux trois fois parce
que j'ai chose parce qu'il faut que je
trouve une soupe parce que machin après
ça va plus qu après tu sors de sa place
à une autre course
après c'est une autre course les trois
avions russes la très dure
c'est parce qu'il ya eu des défaillances
je le vois pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aïe
elle fait vite invité derrière c'est
envoyé
[Musique]
je veux dire 3 arpentait c'est un très
bon chrono c'est mon meilleur chrono en
championnat j'ai jamais fait si bien en
grand championnat
et puis 8e c'est pas une tare j'ai tout
donné j'ai rien à regretter
je me suis battu je suis tombé sur plus
fort et je te vide
j'ai pas bien faire et coup quand il y
aurait fallu de flairer et qui est vaste
à pouvoir les scuds fait mal c'est que
on on le laisse finir pour te virer
derrière et puis en plus la même pas
d'image quoi alors c'est ça qui te fais
un appel il ya même pas d'image pour te
montrer quoi que ce soit la faute ou
quoi que ce soit donc c'est ça qui est
un peu un peu dégueulasse qu un peu
dégueulasse
[Musique]
tu as vu il ya le monde entier qui
étaient là un papa il a fait le mea il a
fait tout ce qu'il pouvait mais s'il
arrive en a pas eu mais peut-être qu'il
en aura une année prochaine si par
hasard
moi ça va c'est une forme quelconque la
plainte qu'a fait 3 39 heures 30
mais je suis disqualifié j'aurais pris
une bouteille hors ravitaillement pour
me vider sur la tête
donc on a fait appel de la décision
bah ouais alors ils te laissent aller au
bout is disqualifié à la fin je suis
dans le vague pendant 2-3 à bord pour
moi c'est toi jusqu'au 34e je suis sûr
que tu vas gagner je suis passé à côté
sans êtes à côté quoi j'étais acteur de
cette course
donc ça c'est le point positif acteurs
de la plus grande course qui ait jamais
eu lieu sur 50 km quand même donc ça
c'est bien il pouvoir par acteur je peux
pas dire que j'étais dans le peloton
j'étais dans les gars qui ont fait que
ça a été une super course
pour a pu regarder derrière donc il ya
encore quatre ans devant il ya rio façon
j'ai toujours dit que 2012
c'était trop tôt pour moi l'arrêt parce
que tu planifie pas un arrêt comme ça
même si cette année le résultat il n'est
pas au bout j'ai quand même prouvé
qu'ils pouvaient me mêler à la bagarre
j'ai fait une heure 17 42 20 km donc ça
peut aussi me laissait envisager de
faire de belles choses sur 20 km donc il
ya plein de choses à plein de nouveau
challenge encore à réaliser puis après
bien sûr finir à copacabana les doigts
de pied en éventail après après
l'arrivée mon 50 bornes avec enfin une
place de finaliste pour un podium à rio
ça sera la cerise sur le gâteau jean lui
terminé sur une bonne note je peux pas
finir là-dessus je peux pas finir
là-dessus donc
donc il ya plein de nouvelles échéances
qui vont arriver encore sur quatre ans
ça c'est sûr d'ici les jeux de rio
yohann diniz va parcourir près de 24
mille kilomètres à l'entraînement en
il aura 38 ans ce sera sa dernière
chance de conquérir une médaille
olympique
[Musique]